am freitag absolvieren
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
landeshauptmann günther platter und
tirols militär kommandant ingo stein
einen lokalaugenschein im neuen corona
zentrum in innsbruck maßgeblich am
kontext racing beteiligt ist auch das
österreichische bundesheer im rahmen
eines assistenzeinsatzes mit 30
soldatinnen und soldaten
landeshauptmann günther platter zeigt
sich über die assistenzleistungen des
bundesheeres sehr zufrieden wenn ein
bedarf besteht in den verschiedenen
bereichen sei es bei katastrophen bei
der bekämpfung der illegalen migration
und jetzt auch bei der korona pandemie
kann man sich auf das österreichische
bundesheer verlassen
ich bin sehr dankbar dafür weil die
heute noch ein gespräch mit der
verteidigungsministerin führen dass der
assistenzeinsatz ausgeweitet wird aber
es ist einfach diese kooperation eine
hervorragende die das österreichische
bundesheer mit der polizei mit dem
blaulicht organisationen und dem land
tirol ist eigentlich einzigartig